von eben keinen sinn ich war mal wieder
in den weiten des internets unterwegs
und habe da eine website gefunden namens
teil burg was für ein ding männermodel
schon rostocks mit xxl penis das ist
seriöse journalisten arbeit in der tat
allerdings soll es im heutigen video
nicht um das genital von shaun ross
gehen und wie lange es denn ist sondern
es soll heute um die erfolgs zwillinge
lisa und lena gehen musicalstars
also
ist irrt music ally noch ich habe damals
selber mal ein paar musical lief
hochgeladen aber das ist halt wirklich
ein jahr her oder so also ich wusste
jetzt nicht dass die plattform wirklich
noch so aktuell ist aber okay lisa und
lena aber die überschrift ist nicht nur
erfolg zwillinge lisa und lena unsere
musical stars sondern darin steht auch
noch schulabbruch mit 15
und als ich das gelesen habe habe ich
mir einfach nur gedacht
sie sind im besten teenager-alter aber
null bock steht bei diesen beiden
mädchen so gar nicht auf dem programm
lisa und lena sind mit ihren süßen 15
jahren richtig dick im geschäft zwölf
millionen menschen folgen dem duo bei
instagram
ich
nicht mal zwei millionen lisa und lena
mandla rangieren in deutschland auf
platz drei in sachen verlauf instagram
ein irrer erfolgskurs so gut läuft es
für die beiden teenies dass sie jetzt
sogar die schule auf eis gelegt haben
ihr plan b laut bunte.de eine ausbildung
als tanzpädagogen an einer dance
akademie haben mit 15 jahren die schule
abgebrochen ich weiß noch dass früher
einige youtuber und freunde von mir auch
überlegt hatten er ich komme jetzt die
zwölfte klasse gymnasium soll ich das
vielleicht abbrechen kein bock jetzt
auch irgendwie fürs abi zu lernen und
ich habe ja schon meinen
realschulabschluss jetzt quasi wenn ich
jetzt aufhöre ich würde es einfach nie
machen die ganze social media sache das
kann man kann alles vorbei sein guckt
euch logan paula näherten quotenmann
gefühlen hat sich darüber übels lustig
machen kann sein dass seine karriere
jetzt vorbei ist weil er einfach ein
scheiß hätten fehler gemacht hat jetzt
kann einfach wirklich bald vorbei sein
und die karriere ist vorbei und die
verdienen dann nichts mehr dann haben
sie nicht mal ein abi oder nicht meinen
realschulabschluss in der tasche die
beiden aber darum soll es heute gar
nicht wirklich geht in dem video ich
habe halt früher wirklich häufig auf
musicals reagiert unter anderem auch auf
musical ist von lisa und lena und ich
dachte ich irgendwie dass dieses ganze
musical eating jetzt mehr oder weniger
tot wäre sage ich mal also das ist jetzt
gar nicht mehr so trassen trend ist dann
habe ich allerdings diesem newsartikel
gesehen ist die beiden wirklich die
schule abgebrochen haben hab mir gedacht
was machen die denn jetzt weil die
können da nicht eigentlich nur musik
machen sondern habt dann halt gesehen
okay die sind noch mega krass auf
instagram unterwegs und dann habe ich
auch wir sehen dass die beiden einen
youtube-kanal haben lisa und lena
official und dort haben sie sogar über
eine halbe million abonnenten ob united
hier helfen entry mit android also ich
soll spaß haben davon träumen und das
dann machen
das werde ich tun als ich dann auf jeden
fall diesen youtube kanal von den
zwillingen hier vor einigen tagen
entdeckt habe bin ich dann auf dem kanal
draufgegangen habe gesehen dass ich als
erstes dieses video hier abspielt und
das ist wohl deren eigener song vor fünf
monaten hochgeladen und 22 millionen
aufrufe j 10 71 branson um ein gott jahr
die der j1 m08 sie 871 brand song ich
würde sagen wir hören jetzt einfach mal
in diesem song rein vorher jedoch noch
zwei ganz kurze sachen erstens ich kenne
die beiden nicht persönlich also das ist
kein angriff oder keine beleidigungen
falls ich den song jetzt irgendwie
kritisieren werde an die beiden
persönlich ich habe noch nie mit ihm
gesprochen
sie können durch die nettesten personen
sein die es auf der welt gibt also es
geht nicht gegen euch persönlich liebe
hat sich in jüngster vergangenheit
kritik von mir zu herzen und persönlich
genommen
deswegen wollte ich das an der stelle
ist sondern mal ganz kurz anmerken und
die zweite sache
der song ist tatsächlich schon fünf
monate alt also ich denke dass einige
von euch den schon kennen ich habe mir
das noch nicht angehört deswegen mache
ich das dann jetzt
okay was ist das was ist was ist dieses
dieses was was ist das j 1 m auge 7.1
stand der kanal dings dass es deren
brand ist oder irgendwie so aber für was
steht das risiko
sie haben video auf ihrem kanal wo sie
erklären warum das so ist also schauen
uns danach aber meine damen und herren
jetzt geht das haben sie gerade gesagt
dass sie nicht auf die afterparty komme
mir seit 15
ihr dürft nicht mal draußen allein
unterwegs sein wenn die party ist nein
ihr seid vielleicht seid ihr nicht nur
cool genug aber ihr seid auch auf jeden
fall nicht alt genug
alles was diese 15-jährigen
schulabbrecher machen wollen ist den
dancefloor rocken
da war mal chef der shop kann ich den
refrain bitte nochmal hören regie
ich muss mal ganz kurz was google neben
ein paar sekunden später
okay das ist das lied my house von flo
rida und der sich zu wort
ich kann nicht singen also ihr habt noch
den refrain wissen
jetzt schauen wir doch einmal bei lisa
und lena in nordrhein und klinge jetzt
einfach mal auf play
habt ihr euch verschrieben wollte die
ersten mal haus cover nennen das da sehe
ich komplett gar keine parallelen nicht
meine es kann ja sein dass mein haus
später veröffentlicht wurde also das von
lisa und lena hier ein 26er siebter 2017
und mein haus kann der auf 2015
da haben wir also nordmann foult drin es
ist nicht lisas und lena schuld
ja da ist
auch geklärt
das wird er
ok moment mein stopp stopp stopp stopp
dass jetzt der offizielle bremsten für
deren marke und wir sehen auch hier da
haben sie vielleicht double trouble das
können von denen sein weil sie sind
zwillinge machen deswegen doppelt er gab
mir hier so ein bisschen weiter
durchgehend haben wir hier auch die
version 10.7 dingsda was sie vielleicht
von deren ist hier auch j1 m0 aber dass
ich ganz lustig fand war tatsächlich
diese szene
er hat adidas tanktops an
das ist doch nicht eure marke oder für
das recht placement hotpot basierender
geguckt im moment ganz kurz die sie
schaut hier doch wolle sie sieht so aus
als wenn ihr gleich aus dem elternhaus
sie zu springen würde
jetzt mai
abitur anscheinend nicht ich muss sagen
ich finde die beiden echt suite zusammen
also die sehen wirklich sehr sehr
sympathisch aus aber ich habe jetzt
wirklich noch nie getroffen hier wie sie
über den zaun gucken wie so kleine süße
hundewelpen die sehen zwar davon dass
ihr vater nicht in der stadt ist sie
deswegen das haus verwüstet und die
beste party aller zeiten machen die
polizei ruft an und alle drinks gehen
auf haus und sie sind es 15 aber hey die
sind echt schmid eigentlich ich würde
sagen ich gebe jetzt hier mal hinten
noch ans ende und wir schauen uns
nochmal die letzten sekunden hier noch
mal kurz an
da haben wir es wieder j 10 71 deswegen
schauen wir uns als nächstes das video
also habe ich jetzt nicht so ganz
verstanden worden wahrscheinlich weil
sie identität wind sind also 17 wann ist
eigentlich nur weil es alt sagt
eigentlich 17 warum eigentlich 17 diesen
15 hat sich wirklich überlegt waren in
welchem monat der geburtstag ist
ihr seid nicht extra dicken ihr seid
excited aber es ist schön dass sie hier
ihre eigene marke haben also wir können
ja mal einmal ganz kurz darauf gehen und
sehen schon das ist die mag es ist und
es ist ein cooler shop und so sagen dass
sie normale preise sticker sowie meinem
shop adresse
aber was haben die denn sonst noch so
für videos da haben sie noch ein
lookbook von den sachen 27 7 gamer noch
ein paar andere videos while we did this
sorgen
when i heard der song
als das ja nicht selbst gemacht also ich
weiß nicht ob ich das anders sie ja als
andere youtuber aber wenn wenn ich
theoretisch irgendwann mal einen song
aus bringen würde und ich werde nie
singen meine damen und herren aber man
kann ja auch sachen machen mit
instrumenten oder mit keine ahnung mit
programmen mit produktionsprogramm dann
wäre es für mich das allerwichtigste das
ist wirklich von mir kommt mir haben
unternehmen schon songs zugeschickt und
meinte lucca die könnte auf seinem kanal
hochladen schreibt da gern einen namen
vor und die fand ich auch geil aber ich
denke mir so die ganze zeit hey das ist
einfach nicht so dass das ist nicht von
mir und förder später würden leute
herausfinden dass es nicht von mir ist
dann ist es scheiße man hat die leute
hintergangen aber lisa und lena sagen
wirklich direkt in dem video fitna falls
es hört sich so an ich will euch
wirklich jetzt nicht irgendwie keine
ahnung ihr irgendwie kann ich irgendwie
angreifen in aller form als herzlich von
euch selbst gesagt so an als wenn ihr
nichts getan hat für diesen song sondern
einfach nur angehört hatte und dachte
der ist cool dass das machen
was
sie also auf deutsch
sagte gerade zu beginn war es echt sehr
verwirrend weil sie haben uns gefragt
wie konnten die all diese sachen wissen
wer weiß alle sachen und welche sachen
und warum was hat das mit dem song zu
tun
was sony in your life
oder sony live
also haben sie wahrscheinlich
dann für euch geschrieben
mainz eher wie ein präsent wie ein
geschenk was ihr den fans macht weil
grenzen giveaway wer dann wird ja einer
den song gewinnen
also ich will jetzt nicht noch weiter
kritisieren für irgendwas weil die sind
halt wirklich 15 und sie haben die
schule abgebrochen
die können halt einfach nicht so krass
ist englisch aber man merkt dass sie
sehr sehr doll so sein wollen so hey hey
it's great with just amazing it fits auf
wie bereits zu beginn gesagt es ist
nichts persönlich gegen die beiden
ich finde die beiden sind sehr sehr sehr
sehr sympathisch und ich würde mich
wirklich gern mit den beiden unterhalten
weil ich glaube sie sind für ihr alter
echt sehr weit aber sie müssen noch
einiges lernen und ich hätte nicht die
schule abgebrochen dadurch bin ich
wirklich so primär auf die idee gekommen
hey ich könnte eigentlich mal auf lisa
und lena reactor das habe ich zuletzt
wirklich von einem jahr auf die musical
dies gemacht hat von denen eine lange
zeit lang nichts mehr gehört und dann
jetzt halt diese meldung gelesen dass
sie die schule abgebrochen haben und ich
bin dann halt einfach nur dachte hey was
machen die denn jetzt hat mir das
angeguckt und fand die musik auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht gut also es ist
einfach nicht meine nicht mein geschmack
also vielleicht feiert ihr ist ja ich
mein ich denke die zielgruppe ist er
relativ jung ich denke da an unter 13
und 14 jährige aber vielleicht kann ich
das nicht so richtig nachvollziehen
das war auf jeden fall meine reaktion
auf lisa und lena auf ihren song und
warum sie den song gemacht haben und auf
ihren job wenn ihr wollte sich auch
weitere sachen reagiere auf andere
youtuber auf andere videos dann schreibt
es mir in die kommentare und dann werde
ich demnächst auf irgendwas anderes
reagieren wo ihr sagt eventuell das ist
total bescheuert oder total lustig gar
keine ahnung was und jetzt meine damen
und herren kommen dass auf der fehler
gewartet hat nämlich das auto das wasser
ziehen
vom video hier können jetzt jemand einen
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen